no matter how much money you have you
can always spend more on tech and you
can always spend more spec'ing out a
really good rendering machine what's
going on guys my name is David Tommy and
welcome back to the channel today we're
gonna be talking about a brand new tower
build whether you're looking at building
a new computer for rendering YouTube
videos potentially doing some photo
editing or maybe even doing some
architectural work you might need a
brand new custom built PC in 2019 now
like I've mentioned you can go and spec
out a computer upwards of ten thousand
dollars if you really want to and
chances are you're never actually going
to use any of those features
however if you are looking to build a
computer just for yourself something
that you're going to be using on a
day-to-day basis and you need it to be
powerful and do a lot of things that
most other computers can't well today
I'm gonna recommend three different
options for you guys to take a look at
what I'm not gonna do in this video is
go through step by step spec by spec and
tell you what's great what isn't I am
gonna tell you the key necessities that
you really need to watch out for and
then I'm also gonna place the specs on
the screen of each option that I'm
recommending this is gonna give you guys
a chance to quickly pause the video take
screenshot if you need to and then go to
your local PC building shop and get
something very similar if you need to or
just check out the different specs for
yourself so let's start off with option
number one which comes in at the
cheapest at about $2,000 unfortunately
two thousand Australian dollars is about
the cheapest you're gonna be able to get
a computer that's gonna last you the
next five even maybe ten years now this
is a minimum recommendation I would
recommend for somebody out there
starting a graphics intensive course
potentially at university or somebody
looking to design YouTube videos to
create a YouTube career or do anything
along those sorts so the key specs here
to take note of is the fact that this is
an i7 processor there's no way I'd
recommend anything under an i7 processor
for any sort of Windows editing work if
you're running a Mac computer
you can usually get away with it on an
i-5 but when you're running the similar
max specs you're spending double the
amount just to get the same result the
second thing that's important here is
the CPU liquid cooling now this isn't
going to be something that most people
are going to recommend on a lower budget
and computer but the simple fact is when
you're actually rendering something
that's quite graphics intensive
potentially doing 3d modeling or even
exporting a 4k video well you're gonna
find that your computer is gonna get
very loud and very hot very very quickly
without proper cooling and without a
proper cooling system in your tower
you're actually gonna see the computer
te8 very quickly and you're gonna go on
waste that $2,000 that you've spent on a
new computer once you start getting into
the higher builds of option 2 an option
3 they come with recommended liquid
cooling as standard because people know
you're going to be using these computers
for very high-end rendering even
high-end gaming sometimes pushes your
computer very far and the last thing
that's a must know on this list is a
simple fact that it's a solid state hard
drive if you're not using a solid-state
hard drive in 2019 your computer is
basically going to seem like the slowest
thing on the planet by no means does
this mean your computer is a worse off
product if it doesn't have a solid state
hard drive it just means that it's gonna
load things a lot lot slower and
especially for people like myself in
particular I'm actually quite impatient
with technology so I like my things to
be short sharp and on the dot when
you're using something like a
solid-state hard drive you know it's
gonna load within milliseconds of you
clicking it and you're never gonna have
to worry and go oh my god this is taking
so long to load so you might be 50 60 70
maybe $100 better off by not going for a
solid-state hard drive but your
solid-state with a minimum of 120
gigabytes of space is gonna be a
lifesaver down the track okay so option
two we move up to about the $3,000 price
bracket now the reason for this jump
predominantly is for the simple fact
that we're moving from an i7 processor
up to an i9 processor the reason I've
selected this eye 9 processor in
particular is a simple fact that it has
eight core and 16 threads in the
itself so when you're doing actual
rendering work exporting 4k videos 8k
videos generating 3d models potentially
doing high-end gaming what your computer
actually utilizes is that thread count
so if you're able to give you a computer
16 32 threads then it's gonna be able to
pump out that image a lot quicker and a
lot smoother this is something I
discovered a long a long way down the
track after trying to render thousands
of different images during my thesis
project and just falling short having to
wait five six hours for some of these
images to render when you start
researching and finding out what lacks
in your computer you find out that
sometimes a simple thread boost in the
i7 2:09 range is potentially a couple
hundred dollars well spent but again
this is moving into territories where
you don't really need to make the
upgrade from the 2k option unless you're
really dedicated to doing some high end
labor-intensive graphic design and
finally option free comes in at the top
price range for me I wouldn't recommend
anything over this budget if you don't
know what you're doing with a computer
and if you aren't building it yourself
once you start building it yourself you
know what the parts are you know what
exactly everything does so you actually
have a better understanding of what
you're putting in whereas option three
comes in at the four thousand Australian
dollar mark now the reason this comes in
at platinum level here is because it is
a 4k rendering machine if you're out
there looking to render 4k RAW files 8k
RAW files or anything of that sort well
this computer is going to be able to
tackle the challenge no problem
whatsoever if your budget does allow for
it make sure you're going upwards of 32
gigs if not potentially to a 64 gigabyte
memory to really allow your computer to
run free when it is exporting and
rendering very high-end graphics
intensive programs it's all well and
good having an amazing tower but what
happens about the screen the keyboard
the mouse the speakers well these are
some things that you can get away with
quite cheap or you can again
do it on a quite expensive side if
you're doing architecture for example
like I did at university I would highly
suggest having a dual screen setup
you're going to be using two screens
almost 99% of the time you're gonna have
one architectural program up here a
different document up here constantly
searching constantly kind of figure
things out and even if you're doing
video editing it is extremely helpful to
have multiple screens to be able to do
your work a lot quicker I found that the
dual screen setup behind me has been
ideal - every single task that I've had
to do along the last five years now if
you haven't watched any of my videos
before I'm an entrepreneur in 2019 I run
multiple businesses and I also work in
the architectural industry so when it
comes to needing very good high-quality
tech I know all about it if you're on a
budget and looking for - 27-inch screens
well a Seuss 27 inch IPS I care is
probably my number one go-to coming in
at about 250 260 Australian dollars each
you can get away with a dual screen
setup for about $500 if I were to
upgrade my two screens behind me and
take a step up well I mean the choice is
quite simple when you're stepping up to
a big screen right now I'd recommend the
49 inch samsung ultra wide curved
display this is one beast of a screen
it's going to set you back almost $1,200
and no it is not 4k because of the
aspect ratio of the actual screen itself
you can't actually physically get the 4k
pixel ratio there now if you're a gamer
and you're looking for something
different again this is an optimal
screen for you to get the maximum real
estate without the split in the middle
where your two screens meet even these
two screens behind me like almost bezel
as' and almost have no black edging but
yet you still notice that there's a bit
of a split down the middle when it comes
to the keyboard and mouse there really
is only one option if you're looking at
this video then I know for a fact that
you're gonna be sitting in that computer
for hours and hours every single day and
carpal tunnel is a serious problem when
you start sitting in a computer for 10
12 hours everything
day so there's really only one keyboard
and one Mouse that I recommend and it's
the one that I personally purchased for
myself Logitech knows exactly what
they're doing in this department the
Logitech MX master s2 mouse is one of
the best mice in the game right now and
I know that they're bringing out s3
version with USB C charging doesn't
really mean too much right now
especially considering the mouse has
about a thirty thirty five day charge
time so you don't have to charge that
often it will be a really good feature
in the future so if you can hold off for
the MX three then definitely worth doing
as for the keyboard the keyboard again
comes from Logitech it's a K 800
illuminated keyboard which makes it
ideal for gaming working rendering doing
anything at all hours of the night
the keys are ultra quiet so you're not
going to keep anybody up while you're
tapping away all night long and again
same system as the Logitech mouse the
batteries last 30 35 plus days so you
don't have to go out and charge it every
single day completely wireless again I
know this isn't ideal for some of you
gamers out there but this isn't really
targeted at the gaming community now
that was a pretty long handle guys I
hope you got some very useful
information out of it I hope you took
some screenshots if you did make sure
you drop a comment down below let me
know what you're thinking about maybe I
can help you design your next
custom-built PC or maybe I can just
offer you some advice of my experience
that I've had over the years pushing
computers to their absolute limits
thanks so much for watching guys if you
haven't already make sure you smash that
subscribe button
20-19 style and I'll see you next Monday